dan starts off this hour in Colorado hi
Dan welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hey
Dave thanks for taking my call
sure what's up I'm 58 almost 59 I've had
a rollercoaster life financially on my
own business 21 years did really well
then really bad should have finally
closed in 2016
probably should have done it five years
earlier took a year off and by some
miracle got a job at 56 in 2017 and now
I'm doing pretty decent make about 80 90
kg air my wife has makes about 54 we
paid off a lot of our credit card debt
that has humilated from the business and
everything else probably about 40k in
the last two and a half years good for
you yeah well it was 92 K but now we're
faced with with some decisions some of
those credit card loans when they're
given out cheap paper at $2.99 fixed you
know ten years ago we use those as sv
loans so SBA instead of the SBA loans
and what happened is we still have some
of that 2.99 fixed left maybe about
5,000 then I was on a disabled vet so I
was able to lock in a three to five refi
in 2012 and I still owe about few oh six
on that mm-hmm
the problem is my retirement only 40,000
and now I'm faced with investing it
making more than the 3.25 or the 299
that I have left over in debt or should
I go ahead and pay that off because
right now I'm looking at 82 before I pay
off my house mm-hmm
and women you met you make a hundred and
forty five thousand dollars a year why
would you be at eighty two paying off
your house it's only $200 I was forced
to refine and what do you you only owe
$200,000 you make one hundred and forty
five thousand right
that's not 82 now we actually know 1982
is when we pay it off
I'm sorry by when I'm aged 82 no that's
ridiculous
you're not let your hear me $200,000 and
you make a hundred and forty five why
would you wait why would you wait until
age 82 to pay that off well first I
wanted to get my credit card debt thank
you
well know at the time was a day right
today you do not have an 82 year old
projection on paying off your home from
today you only have two hundred and
eleven thousand dollars in debt to your
name and you make a hundred and forty
five fifty thousand dollars a year out
of a hundred and forty five as you
living on ninety and that puts you out
of that in four years with everything by
the time you're selling D right would
you do that no I'm just saying I'm just
saying don't don't don't throw out the
dramatic eighty two-year-old because
that's just dumb that's not even true so
now let's go back and what what we teach
is what's called what we call the baby
steps baby step one save a thousand
dollars to is be out of debt everything
but your house you've got five thousand
dollars you need to knock that in the
head right now get that done as soon as
possible you have any money and savings
at all that's not retirement yeah we
started saving up at six months we have
seven thousand and write a check today
and pay off write a check today and pay
off the credit card and cut it up even
though it's two points you have not
gonna borrow money on a credit card to
build wealth today stop this stop
playing with his dad gum debt it is not
your in its not been your friend it's
still not your friend the faster you get
rid of the debt the faster you build
wealth
so next step is write cheque today pay
off the credit card then the next step
is to have an emergency fund of three to
six months of expenses we call that baby
step three baby step three is three to
six months of expenses I want you to
rebuild your savings as quickly as you
can for a rainy day fund you guys have
seen some rainy days you know there's a
need for that have that in place in your
all's house that's probably 20,000 bucks
I want you safe okay
it's not
be very high-performing any but you're
gonna do really really fast cuz you make
really good money and you're gonna be on
a budget now or you make every dollar
behave because you're 56 and you have
about a 14 year horizon to get
everything done and in place
well I'm 59 now almost okay then you've
got an 11 year horizon till you're 70
okay so we've got to get to rockin on
this stuff so you're gonna get these
first two or three little things done
very quickly then baby step four is I
want you to start saving 15% of your
income that's $20,000 a year into
retirement plans until we get the house
paid off above that I want you to attack
this house and get it paid off but you
need to be on beans and rice right now
you don't be running around all over the
world traveling you don't need to be
eating out every night you do need to be
on a written budget the two of you are
in agreement we've got some catching up
to do because here's what I want you to
do if you will save twenty to thirty
thousand dollars a year for ten years
you're gonna have about six or eight
hundred thousand dollars and your house
will have been paid off years before
that say 140 is your in 145 is your
income minus 20,000 going into
retirement okay that leaves us a hundred
and twenty two thousand dollars to live
and pay big chunks on the house
let's take fifty and throw it at the
house a year above putting your money
into retirement fifty a year in four
years you're not even 65 years old your
house is paid for you'll have at that
point about two hundred thousand dollars
in retirement and you've got five more
years till you're 70 to put another
three or four hundred thousand side and
it'll double again so that's where
you're headed if you follow the baby
steps that we teach but you're not going
to build wealth in the short term by
borrowing on your house to invest in
others not paying off the house so that
I can invest more that has not been a
formula that's worked for anyone hold on
the line I'll send you a copy the book
the Total Money Makeover it will show
you exactly what to do step by step it
show you these baby steps I'm talking
about pay off your credit card today
immediately build that emergency fund of
twenty thousand as fast as you can then
start putting fifteen percent into
retirement
and everything else on the house the
house is gone when the house is gone you
come back and you load retirement up and
even more and use all of your income to
build wealth and you guys have got to
stop spending you don't have time to
waste money you got to be on a budget
and do this hold on I'll send you a copy
the book the Total Money Makeover